Tất cả các bạn tự tưởng nhất bản, sân nè và kê chỉ khẩn lệnh chính vụ sẽ tăng tóc đặt một tiêu chi tối qua phòng.
Tự đường 2 phần trăm chỉ đếp bệnh ngày trong năm tài chính hiện tại, thấy vì kéo sài đến năm 2020,
không trai bị bệnh như kiế hoại trưa đó.
Tâm ký này cho thấy trước kêu đảng chuyển tư cách tiếp tận phòng thuộc chuyến thống,
sang chiến lược chủ đầm hơn cho một cạnh cạnh chiến anh ninh khu bực lao thang.
Bà tất cả chỉ nhấn mạnh qua phòng mạnh phẩn giản với nền tình tế vấn.
Giờ đó chính phổ theo đồ chính sách tại khoảng mở giống, nhằm tích tích tăng trường, săm xong kìm xan ở tâm,
đề dưới chiến nềm tình tì trường.
Về tăng chiến nền sách của phòng cũng được lòng ghét trong chiến lược an ninh ku ra,
bởi các biển pháp tài chính bộ sông.
Lê được xem là bước đi để hình lại phai cho của nhật bản trong cầu chúc an ninh khu bực.
Đồng thời phản nền xử thấy đổi trong tư dưới chế lược của cho kêu, dưới thời lãnh gạo mới.